Now how many communication events are happening in in every
round? Well, it's order of N communication events per every
round, because every processor is sending a message to another
processor in, in every round. And therefore, the amount of communication
that's happening is order of N, where N is the
number of processors that are participating in this barrier. So
now you can quickly see what's going to happen in the
next round, and the next round, k is going to be equal
to one and therefore. I'm going to choose, each
processor is going to choose a neighbor to send the message
to based on this formula that I've, that I have
here. So in round zero, for instance, what we did
was, P0 is sending a message a neighbor that
is one distant from it because k was zero. And
now. In round one case one and therefore P0 is
going to be sending a message to a neighbor that is
two distant from it. So P0 will send to P2 and similarly P1 two distant from it
P3, P2 two distant P4. P4. Too distant
from it, in cyclic order, is going to be P1.
So it's sending a message to P1. So
that's the round one of communication with k equal
to one, round one of communication. Where once
again, order of N messages are being exchanged among
these processes to indicate that this round is complete.
Just as I said about Round zero, every processor will
know that this round is complete when it receives a
message from its ordained neighbor. So in this case, P2
is going to expect to receive a message from P0,
and it has also sent its message to P4, its
ordained neighbor to which it is supposed to send the
message in this round. Once it is done, P2 knows
that round one is over and it can progress
to the next round. So the independent decision is
being made by each one of these processes in
terms of knowing that this particular round is over
and they can progress to the next round of
the dissemination barrier. And just as I mentioned in
the previous round. All of these communications happen in
parallel, so if the interconnection network has a redundant parallel
path these parallel, these parallel paths can be
exploited by the dissemination barrier. In order to
do this communication very effectively. So the next
round, meaning round number two. K is equal
to two, and therefore, what we're going to
do is, every one of these processors is
going to be choosing a neighbor that is
four distant from itself. So in other words,
P0 is going to send a message to its neighbor
that is four distant, that is, P4. P1 is going to
send it to four distant. Which means if you wrap
it around, it's going to be P0 and so on. So
this is the communication that's happening in round two
where every processor is sending a message to its neighbor
who is four distant because gave with the two four
distant from itself. So just sort of biz, belaboring the point
the gossip in round two. Is over, so
far as P3 is concerned, when it has received
a gossip message from its four distant neighbor, which
happens to be P4. And it has also sent
a message to its four distant neighbor, P2
in this case. At this point, every one of
these processes knows that round two of gossip is
compelte. And, similar to what I've been emphasizing all
along, parallel communication pads in the interconnection network,
can be fully exploited, by the dissemination barrier algorithm.